This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The most popular sport in the world has been relatively slow to catch on here in the United States. There's this episode of The Simpsons that I think captures the disdain with which some Americans regard the rest of humanity's favorite game. It starts with the family watching TV. Open wide for some soccer! The Caminetto Soccer Association is coming to spring for you. It's all here. Fast kickin' low-scored and he ties. You bet.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。世界上最受欢迎的运动在美国却一直难以流行起来。《辛普森一家》里有一集，我认为很好地捕捉到了部分美国人对这项全世界最受欢迎运动的蔑视。故事开始于一家人正在看电视。“张大嘴巴，迎接足球吧！卡米内托足球协会即将为你带来精彩赛事。一切尽在其中。快速踢球，低比分，他平局了。没错。”
Hey Dad, I'll come you never taking us to see a soccer game. I don't know. So the Simpsons decide to go to the game, and the stands are packed. But the fans' enthusiasm quickly evaporates as the game gets going. Half-back passes to the center, back to the wing, back to the center. Center holds it, holds it, holds it. Blowing! Come on, you snores! Do something! I think it's fair to say that Homer and crusty the clown are echoing a common complaint about soccer that you hear in the United States a lot.
“嘿，老爸，我怎么从来没见你带我们去看过足球赛。”“我不知道。”于是辛普森一家决定去看比赛，看台上挤满了人。但随着比赛开始，球迷们的热情很快就消散了。“中场传球给中路，回传给边路，再回传给中路。中路控球，控球，还是控球。真无聊！加油，你们这些睡神！做点什么吧！”我认为，荷马和库斯提小丑说出了美国人对足球常见的一种抱怨，这种抱怨你经常能听到。
That it's not exciting enough. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. They don't score enough points to lament these narrow-minded touchdown lovers. I completely disagree with this perspective, but even I have to admit that soccer can be a low scoring affair. Professional teams routinely win games one to nothing, or worse yet battle for 90 minutes and settle for a 0-0 draw. But whatever your feelings about the relative excitement of the beautiful game, Soccer was undoubtedly more boring 30 years ago.
“它不够刺激。”这是制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。他们抱怨这些目光短浅的达阵爱好者说足球得分太少。我完全不同意这种观点，但即使是我也不得不承认，足球确实可能是一场低比分的比赛。职业球队经常以1比0赢下比赛，或者更糟的是，苦战90分钟后以0比0平局收场。但无论你对这项“美丽运动”的刺激程度有何看法，足球在30年前无疑更加无聊。
The world was in general agreement, the game was too slow, and it needs to be more dynamic. This is Soccer writer, or football writer, Adam Hurrey. And Adam says that the main culprit, slowing the game down was the goalkeeper. So the goalkeeper became very useful in controlling the pace of the game. Basically teams would score a goal or two, and then they would do anything they could
全世界都一致认为，比赛节奏太慢，需要更具活力。这是足球作家亚当·赫里。亚当说，拖慢比赛节奏的罪魁祸首是守门员。守门员在控制比赛节奏方面变得非常有用。基本上，球队进一两个球后，就会想尽一切办法
just to kill time and protect the lead. And the easiest way to do that was just to pass the ball to the goalkeeper. Who back then could just pick the ball up and run a few seconds off the clock before throwing it back into play. And you could do this as many times as you wanted. It kind of resulted in real sort of almost comic book scenarios where they would kick the ball bets the goalkeeper from the halfway line, from free kicks that they had in the opposition half, just because they knew that that would waste pressure seconds, the opposition team simply couldn't have the ball.
来拖延时间并保住领先优势。最简单的方法就是把球传给守门员。当时的守门员可以直接抱起球，在把球重新投入比赛前消耗几秒钟时间。而且你可以随心所欲地重复这个动作。这导致了几乎像漫画一样的场景：他们从半场线、从对方半场的任意球位置把球踢给守门员，仅仅因为他们知道这能浪费宝贵的几秒钟，让对方球队根本无法控球。
People finally got fed up with this uninspiring tactic during the 1990 World Cup in Italy. Now, nostalgia kind of paints the World Cup of 1990 as a wonderful tournament, but at the time it was regarded as kind of the power of a cynical football. Lots of low scoring games, lots of passing the ball back to the keeper, lots of time wasting. There was one story about a game at Italian 90 between Egypt and Republic of Ireland where someone totalled up the amount of time that Irish goalkeeper Pat Bonner had the ball in his hands and he added up to six minutes.
在1990年意大利世界杯期间，人们终于受够了这种乏味的战术。现在，怀旧情绪将1990年世界杯描绘成一场精彩的赛事，但在当时，它被视为一种“愤世嫉俗的足球”的代表。大量的低比分比赛，大量的回传给门将，大量的时间浪费。有一个关于意大利世界杯埃及对阵爱尔兰共和国比赛的故事，有人统计了爱尔兰门将帕特·邦纳手持球的时间，总计达到了六分钟。
In other words, fans spent about 7% of the game watching the goalkeeper just hold the ball. Set Blatter, who was the general secretary of FIFA at the time, he said this is not why people go to watch football. It's one of the rare things he did get right in his time in FIFA. But he was spot on, he was absolutely right. This is not entertaining football. This is not inspired people. And there is no skill in simply standing there holding the ball in one hand.
换句话说，球迷们花了大约7%的比赛时间看着守门员抱球。时任国际足联秘书长的塞普·布拉特说：“人们看足球不是为了这个。”这是他在国际足联任职期间为数不多做对的事情之一。但他一针见血，他绝对是对的。这不是娱乐性的足球。这不会激励人心。而且仅仅站在那里单手抱球，没有任何技术含量可言。
Something had to be done. And so in 1992, the International Football Association Board, the committee in charge of determining the rules of soccer, made a minor change to the laws of the game. From that season forward, in every league throughout the world, if the player intentionally kicked the ball back to the goalkeeper, the goalkeeper could no longer use their hands. So any deliberate pass back to the goalkeeper from any place on the pitch could not be picked
必须采取行动。于是，在1992年，负责制定足球规则的国际足球协会理事会（IFAB）对比赛规则做了一项微小的修改。从那个赛季开始，在世界各地的每一个联赛中，如果球员故意将球踢回给守门员，守门员将不能再用手接球。因此，从球场任何位置故意回传给守门员的球都不能用手接。
up. FIFA put out a press release about the new rule, where they came down really hard on the goalkeepers. It was entitled goalkeepers are not above the law. And they were very strong about this. They said the goalkeeper has a very rare privilege in football, the use of his hands, but it is a privilege that should not be abused. Time wasting is one of the worst forms of unsporting behaviour, because it attempts to deny opponents a fair chance of using the fuller lot of time to use their skills to win the game.
国际足联发布了一份关于新规则的新闻稿，对守门员的态度非常强硬。标题是《守门员并非凌驾于法律之上》。他们对此态度非常坚决。他们说：“守门员在足球比赛中拥有一种非常罕见的特权，即使用他的手，但这是一种不应被滥用的特权。拖延时间是最糟糕的非体育行为之一，因为它试图剥夺对手利用全部时间发挥技能赢得比赛的公平机会。”
The backpast law might seem like a pretty subtle tweak to the rules of soccer, but over time, it would completely transform the game in ways that FIFA could never have envisioned. This little rule change would become one of the most consequential in the history of the sport and force nearly every player on the field to adapt. But in the short term, the rule change would cause an existential crisis for one player in particular. The goalkeeper. The goalkeeper has always been a unique specialist position,
回传球规则看起来像是对足球规则的一个相当微妙的调整，但随着时间的推移，它以国际足联从未预料到的方式彻底改变了这项运动。这一小小的规则改变成为了足球史上最具影响力的规则之一，并迫使场上几乎每一名球员做出调整。但在短期内，这一规则改变给一名球员带来了生存危机。那就是守门员。守门员一直是一个独特的专业位置，
like a field goal kicker in American football, or a coxen in rowing. They even wear a different colored shirt from their teammates, as if to signify, I am not like the rest of you. The most obvious difference is that they're allowed to do something that no one else in the field can. Touch the ball with their hands. Goldkeepers have this strange superpower, which they use to ruin everyone else's fun.
就像美式足球中的踢球手，或者赛艇中的舵手。他们甚至穿着与队友不同颜色的球衣，仿佛在暗示：“我和你们不一样。”最明显的区别是，他们被允许做场上其他人不能做的事情：用手触球。守门员拥有这种奇怪的超能力，他们用它来破坏其他所有人的乐趣。
Soccer is the most popular sport in the world and what most people love about it is the goals, and it's actually our ambition to prevent goals from happening, so we're sort of trying to disappoint the entire world. This is Justin Bryant, a former professional fund-ruiner who is currently the goalkeeping coach for the North Carolina State Women Soccer Team. Bryant is from the United States, but he played professionally in England in the 80s and 90s for a really small club called Borum Wood FC. They paid me, I think, 50 pounds a week plus room and board.
“足球是世界上最受欢迎的运动，大多数人热爱它是因为进球，而我们的志向实际上是阻止进球发生，所以我们某种程度上是在试图让全世界失望。”这是贾斯汀·布莱恩特，一位前职业“乐趣破坏者”，目前是北卡罗来纳州立大学女子足球队的守门员教练。布莱恩特来自美国，但他在80和90年代在英国的一家名为博勒姆伍德FC的小俱乐部踢过职业足球。“他们付给我，我想是每周50英镑，外加食宿。”
So, by the slimmest of margins I made living, but I did. Justin was this kid from Florida, living out of a bed and breakfast, trying to follow his dreams. But it wasn't always easy. The fields were in bad shape, the fans were sometimes hostile.
所以，我勉强维持生计，但我做到了。贾斯汀是个来自佛罗里达的孩子，住在民宿里，试图追逐他的梦想。但这并不总是那么容易。场地状况很差，球迷有时充满敌意。
And the style of playing England at the time wasn't very sophisticated. Teams would just kick these long balls forward and hope that their big bruising striker would make something happen. You know, I had to very quickly get used to balls being played in the box and three or four great big ball-dehitted tattooed guys flying in,
而且当时英国的比赛风格并不太成熟。球队只会把球长传向前，希望他们身材高大、强壮的前锋能有所作为。你知道，我必须很快习惯球被踢进禁区，三四个身材高大、满身纹身的家伙冲过来，
trying to run me over essentially. If the goalkeepers job to go grab that ball, no matter what. Yeah, it's actually counter to several million years of human evolution, throwing ourselves, hurling ourselves in front of a ball that's moving at a high rate of speed. Some people say you have to be crazy to be a goalkeeper. Justin doesn't love that word, but he says that goalkeepers are just wired a little bit differently than everybody else. If he spots a soccer team at the airport, for example, he can recognize the goalkeeper right away.
本质上是想把我撞倒。如果守门员的工作是去抓住那个球，无论如何都要做到。是的，这实际上违背了数百万年的人类进化，我们要把自己投掷出去，挡在一个高速移动的球前面。有些人说当守门员必须得疯。贾斯汀不喜欢这个词，但他认为守门员只是比其他人稍微“不同”一点。例如，如果他在机场看到一支足球队，他能立刻认出守门员。
It's a different personality type. It's a different mindset, a different mentality. They carry themselves differently. They express themselves differently. And what are the telltale signs of a goalkeeper? I don't know. There's goalkeepers tend to have kind of a knowing smirk. That's the best way I'd put it.
“这是一种不同的人格类型。这是一种不同的思维方式，一种不同的心态。他们的举止不同。他们表达自己的方式也不同。”那么守门员有什么明显的特征吗？“我不知道。守门员往往有一种心知肚明的坏笑。这是我能想到的最好的形容方式。”
It's almost like they're saying, yeah, I know. I know what you think, but I still like to do this. I grew up playing soccer, and I never wanted to be the goalkeeper. In part, because it felt like such a thankless job. When goalies do everything right, they get taken for granted. But if they make one mistake, everyone notices.
这就像他们说：“是的，我知道。我知道你在想什么，但我还是喜欢这样做。”我从小踢足球，但我从来不想当守门员。部分原因是这感觉像是一份吃力不讨好的工作。当守门员一切做得很好时，他们被视为理所当然。但如果他们犯了一个错误，每个人都会注意到。
We can make other fools of ourselves. We can make out of fools of ourselves. We can make just the most horrific mistakes that lose games, and it's very evident to everybody watching when that happens. What a fatal era! What on earth is he doing? But what happens to the goalkeeper? I think that's every goalkeeper's nightmare where you have nothing to do the whole game, and then the other team gets one chance, and it squirms right under your hands and into
“我们可以让自己出丑。我们可以让自己出丑。我们可以犯下最可怕的错误导致输球，当这种情况发生时，所有观看比赛的人都看得一清二楚。”“多么致命的失误！他到底在干什么？”但守门员会发生什么呢？我认为那是每个守门员的噩梦：整场比赛你无事可做，然后对方球队获得了一次机会，球从你的手下溜进了
the goal and you lose by that goal. Whoops, it's a daisy! Oh, pal, I'm one of the mistakes! How on earth did you do that? He completely misjudged it! That has to be the worst mistake that I have ever seen from an excellent goalkeeper. That's a recipe for sleepless night or two. For that reason, the goalkeeper developed a reputation
球门，你就因为那个球输了。“哎呀，真是个失误！哦，伙计，我是失误之一！你怎么会犯那种错？他完全判断错了！那一定是我见过的优秀守门员犯下的最糟糕的错误。”那是导致失眠一两晚的秘诀。出于这个原因，守门员获得了
as kind of a lonely outsider. French existentialist philosopher Albert Camus was a goalkeeper. If that tells you anything. You know, obviously, I've been around goalkeepers now as my profession for a quarter century, and there are a lot of individualists, iconoclasts, loners, whatever you want to call them. We are kind of a loan task with keeping the ball out of the net with our hands. For Justin Bryant's whole life that had been his one job to keep the ball out of the net with his hands, that is until 1992.
一种孤独局外人的名声。法国存在主义哲学家阿尔贝·加缪曾是一名守门员。如果这能说明什么的话。你知道，显然，我作为职业守门员已经有四分之一个世纪了，有很多个人主义者、反传统者、独行侠，随你怎么称呼他们。我们是一种负责用手把球挡在网外的孤独任务。对于贾斯汀·布莱恩特的一生来说，这就是他唯一的工作：用手把球挡在网外，直到1992年。
with his hands. That is until 1992. I didn't hear about it until it actually did happen. Like, it just, I think anecdotally somebody mentioned, oh, starting next season, you can't pick up a back pass. And I just couldn't, I couldn't believe it because there were an awful lot of goalkeepers that weren't suited for it at all. Goalkeepers in England were trained in how to block shots,
用手。直到1992年。“直到它真正发生，我才听说。就像，我想是有人随口提了一句，哦，从下个赛季开始，你不能接回传球了。我简直不敢相信，因为有太多守门员根本不适合这样做。”英国的守门员受训于如何封堵射门、
catch crosses, and fight for loose balls. All things you mostly do with your hands. A training session in the old days, a goalkeeper session in the 1980s wouldn't involve playing the ball with your feet at all, at no point. But now, if someone on their own team passed them the ball, the goalkeeper would be stripped of their superpowers. They would need to use their feet,
接传中球，以及争抢松散的球。所有这些大多是用手完成的。在过去，1980年代的守门员训练根本不涉及用脚踢球，一点也不。但现在，如果他们自己球队的人把球传给他们，守门员的超能力就会被剥夺。他们需要用脚，
just like everybody else. And that turned out to be a bit of a problem, because a lot of them just didn't know how. 1992 was a big year for English soccer. It was the start of a brand new, highly commercialized league that would go on to become the most lucrative in the world, the English Premier League. There were big money sponsorships and a new TV deal. The whole country was watching soccer. But that first weekend of games in this critical season
就像其他人一样。这结果成了一个问题，因为他们很多人根本不知道怎么做。1992年对英国足球来说是重要的一年。那是一个全新的、高度商业化的联赛的开始，它后来成为了世界上最赚钱的联赛——英超联赛。有大额赞助和新的电视转播协议。全国都在看足球。但在那个关键赛季的第一个周末，
were pretty sloppy. We had a weekend full of goalkeepers making horrendous errors because they just didn't know what to do. That's Adam, hurry again. goalkeepers were in a blind panic. The ball would be kicked back to them as it used to be because that's defenders had a habit of doing that.
比赛相当草率。“我们经历了一个充满守门员犯下可怕错误的周末，因为他们根本不知道该怎么办。”这是亚当·赫里。“守门员陷入了盲目的恐慌。球会像过去一样被踢回给他们，因为后卫习惯那样做。”
But then once the ball was at the fate that they just had sheer terror. Over the first few months, it was as if all the goalkeepers in England were working together to collaboratively produce one long blooper reel. There were slips and falls and bizarre own goals. There was a particularly comical episode involving the goalkeeper for Sheffield United, a man named Simon Tracy. Now, I'm going to take you through this kind of calamity point by point because it really does sum up the immediate effects of the Bat Pass law. He was pass the ball back, very
“但一旦球到了脚下，他们就感到了纯粹的恐惧。”在最初的几个月里，就好像英国所有的守门员都在合作制作一部长长的失误集锦。有滑倒、摔倒和离奇的乌龙球。有一个特别滑稽的插曲涉及谢菲尔德联队的守门员，一个名叫西蒙·特雷西的人。现在，我要带你逐点回顾这场灾难，因为它确实总结了回传球规则的直接影响。他接到回传球，非常
simple pass, he could have dealt with it quite easily. But now that the ball was at his feet, a striker from the other team started charging at Tracy fast, knowing full well that he probably didn't have great foot skills. And Tracy clearly panicked. Tracy, he's going to get caught here if he's not careful. Then he tried to do a little bit of skill to get away from this attacker running straight end and ended up running sideways towards the side of the pitch. Tracey ended up dribbling the ball straight out of bounds. And then it went from comedy to forest because the other team just needed to do a throw-in and they could shoot on an empty net since Tracey was so far out of position.
简单的传球，他本可以轻松处理。但现在球到了脚下，对方球队的一名前锋开始快速冲向特雷西，很清楚他可能脚下技术不好。特雷西显然慌了。“特雷西，如果不小心他会被断球的。”然后他试图用一点技巧来摆脱这个直冲过来的攻击者，结果却横向跑向了球场边。特雷西最终把球直接带出了界外。然后情况从喜剧变成了闹剧，因为对方球队只需要掷界外球，由于特雷西位置太靠前，他们可以直接射空门。
And so Tracey tried to stop the ball boy from giving the ball to the other team. He ended up kind of wrestling the ball from this small child. He was given a red card and kicked out of the game. So within about maybe 15 seconds, the whole drastic effects of the backpast law have been summed up. Goldkeeper receiving a pass, not knowing what to do, trying to be clever, then ending up in this calamity where he got sent off because he just didn't know what to do. More often though, when someone passed the ball back to the goalkeeper, the keeper would just kick it away as far as he could.
于是特雷西试图阻止球童把球给对方球队。他最终从这个小孩手中抢球。他被出示红牌罚下场。所以在大约15秒内，回传球规则的所有剧烈影响都被总结出来了。守门员接到传球，不知道该怎么办，试图耍小聪明，最后陷入了被罚下的灾难，因为他就是不知道该怎么办。不过更多时候，当有人把球传回给守门员时，门将会直接把它踢得越远越好。
Sometimes straight up the field, but often the ball would end up out of bounds. Sometimes 15 rows up in the stadium, sometimes completely out of the stadium. So it wasn't a very aesthetically pleasing development at first. So the first reaction was how has this improved our game? If anything, it's less enjoyable to watch because now the ball's in the stand instead of the goalkeeper's hands. World Soccer Magazine launched a Saver Backpass campaign. I remember thinking that as a fan of the game, Yish, this is not, you know, the greatest thing to look at and I think they're going to regret it
有时直接踢向前方，但球往往会出界。有时踢到看台第15排，有时完全踢出体育场。所以起初这并不是一个美观的发展。所以第一反应是：这怎么改进了我们的比赛？如果说有什么不同的话，那就是观看体验变差了，因为现在球在看台上，而不是在守门员手里。《世界足球》杂志发起了“拯救回传球”运动。“我记得当时作为球迷，我想，哎呀，这可不是什么好看的东西，我想他们会后悔的。”
and I even wondered in the early days if they would change it back. Another goalkeeper from that time, Craig Forest, remembers the rule change causing friction between goalkeepers and defenders. Forest played for a primarily team called Ipswich Town, and he says that that first season his defenders would forget about the rule change and pass him the ball in these really dangerous situations. They would pass the ball back to you forgetting when that rule came in that you couldn't pick it up.
我甚至在早期怀疑他们是否会改回去。当时另一位守门员克雷格·福雷斯特记得规则的改变在守门员和后卫之间造成了摩擦。福雷斯特效力于一支名为伊普斯维奇城的球队，他说那个赛季他的后卫们会忘记规则的改变，在非常危险的情况下把球传给他。“他们会把球传回给你，忘记了那条规则，你不能用手接。”
Sometimes it was slip their mind and they would lose focus and pass you one back and not realize that oh no no no you can't pick it up and it ear under too much pressure. He remembers one moment in particular where a teammate whipped a hard pass right at his chest and he's yelling at me why didn't I just pick it up. The two goalkeepers that I spoke to for this story were the lucky ones. They had decent foot skills and so over time they were able to adjust to the role change. But that wasn't the case for every goalkeeper. And if anybody wasn't at all comfortable with playing with your feet, you got found out really quickly. And you could be good at everything else. But if you're not good at playing with your feet or striking a ball first time, and dealing with that, you'd be out of the game and
“有时他们会疏忽，失去专注，传回一个球，却没意识到，哦不不不，你不能用手接，这让你承受了太大的压力。”他记得有一个时刻，队友把球猛地传向他的胸口，他对我大喊：“为什么你不直接接住它？”我为这个故事采访的两位守门员是幸运的。他们有不错的脚下技术，所以随着时间的推移，他们能够适应规则的改变。但并非每个守门员都是如此。如果有人根本不习惯用脚踢球，你很快就会被发现。你可以擅长其他一切，但如果你不擅长用脚踢球或第一时间处理球，你就会被淘汰出局，
aren't beat. And a lot of guys did kill the game for them as well. Over the course of the 90s, lots of goalkeepers were just weeded out because they couldn't adapt to this new reality. So there's a tragic element to this because there are hundreds of footballers who simply of no use, almost straight away. Suddenly, they were forced to do things that they simply weren't trained for, that a whole generation of goalkeepers who have been brought up to rely on their hands only,
“被打败了。”很多人的职业生涯也因此终结。在90年代的过程中，许多守门员因为无法适应这种新现实而被淘汰。所以这里有一个悲剧因素，因为有数百名足球运动员几乎立刻就变得毫无用处。突然间，他们被迫做他们根本没有受过训练的事情，整整一代被培养成只依赖双手的守门员，
were suddenly rendered kind of redundant. Right, it's almost like jobs lost to automation or something. Yeah, exactly right. It's a little bit like that. But once this law came in and wreaked havoc with their entire existence, they looked even more lonely than before because they looked almost obsolete. And you've got to feel for these guys. Like the goalkeeper was already this isolated lonely player, and then just pull the rug out
突然变得有些多余了。“对，这几乎就像是自动化导致的工作岗位流失。”“是的，完全正确。有点像那样。”但一旦这项法律出台并对他们的整个存在造成了破坏，他们看起来比以前更孤独了，因为他们看起来几乎过时了。你不得不为这些人感到难过。就像守门员本来就是这种孤立、孤独的球员，然后规则一改，就把地毯从
from under them with this rule change and tell them, well now you need to have this whole new set of skills that you weren't trained for. But you know, over time, the role really became quite successful. I mean, for one, it completely did away with time-wasting, which was its initial purpose. And then after a few rough years, goalkeepers really started developing the necessary foot skills. Yeah, so then what happened is we changed the way we trained goalkeepers, so you know, we didn't take long for coaches to realize, gosh, we've got to prepare goalkeepers for this demand. Justin Bryant says he had
他们脚下抽走，告诉他们：“好吧，现在你需要掌握一套你从未受过训练的全新技能。”但你知道，随着时间的推移，这项规则确实变得非常成功。我的意思是，首先，它彻底消除了拖延时间，这是它的最初目的。然后经过几年的磨合，守门员真的开始发展出必要的脚下技术。“是的，所以后来发生的事情是我们改变了训练守门员的方式，所以你知道，教练们没花多久就意识到，天哪，我们必须让守门员为这种需求做好准备。”贾斯汀·布莱恩特说他
a goalkeeping coach at Borum Wood who really made a point at this. Once the new law came into play, he started adding an element of playing the ball with your feet to every session, almost every activity, every drill. So we just started adding this kind of thing, training. Everyone did it, took a while, but everyone started incorporating it, and the goalkeepers got better. Was it fun to suddenly have this new challenge? It was. It was fun because I liked the feeling of being
在博勒姆伍德有一位守门员教练，他真的强调了这一点。新法律生效后，他开始在每次训练、几乎每个活动、每个练习中加入用脚处理球的元素。“所以我们只是开始加入这种训练。每个人都这么做了，花了一段时间，但每个人都开始将其纳入其中，守门员们也变得更好了。”突然面临这个新挑战有趣吗？“很有趣。这很有趣，因为我喜欢那种成为
a more complete player. I think it made us feel better about being goalkeepers because now we weren't just these weirdos who stood back there and swatted at the ball with our hands. We were soccer players. But the goalkeepers weren't the only ones who had to adjust the rule. From the perspective of the defenders, the game changed a lot too. Before when they got into a sticky situation, they could just pass the ball back to the goalkeeper
一个更全面球员的感觉。我认为这让我们对成为守门员感觉更好，因为现在我们不仅仅是那些站在后面用手拍球的怪胎。我们是足球运动员。”但守门员并不是唯一需要适应规则的人。从后卫的角度来看，比赛也发生了很大变化。以前当他们陷入困境时，他们可以直接把球传回给守门员，
who would pick it up. And now they didn't have this escape route, they didn't have this kind of fail safe. So they had to kind of evolve very quickly as well. And as defenders and goalkeepers adjusted to this rule and got more skilled with their feet, it completely changed the way the game was played. Instead of just booting long balls forward, teams started focusing on keeping control of the ball with skill for passing. Possession of the ball became imperative. If you had the ball, the other team couldn't score.
守门员会接住它。而现在他们没有了这条逃生路线，没有了这种“故障保险”。所以他们也必须非常迅速地进化。随着后卫和守门员适应了这条规则并提高了脚下技术，比赛的进行方式彻底改变了。球队不再只是把球长传向前，而是开始专注于通过熟练的传球来控制球权。控球变得至关重要。如果你控球，对方球队就无法得分。
That was pretty much the ethos here. And that starts from the back. If you can have a goalkeeper who's fully capable of joining him in the play, then he becomes an extra player than what you may have had 20 years previously. So it became an opportunity rather than a restriction. Adam Hurrier says that the rule change even made players more physically fit. Because before whenever anyone passed it back to the goalkeeper, the outfield players had this moment to catch their breath. Now there's no let up. The action is non-stop. The average outfield player today runs about seven miles in a single match.
“这基本上就是这里的精神。而且这从后场开始。如果你能拥有一名完全有能力参与比赛的守门员，那么他就会成为比你20年前可能拥有的球员多出的一个额外球员。”所以这变成了一个机会，而不是一种限制。亚当·赫里说，规则的改变甚至让球员们的身体素质变得更好。因为以前每当有人把球传回给守门员时，外场球员都有喘息的机会。现在没有松懈了。动作是连续不断的。今天的外场球员平均每场比赛跑动约七英里。
Now they're all like Olympic de-Cathletes. They're all built like middleweight boxes. I think what we have now is a completely different sport. It's quicker, it's more dynamic. Players have to be fitter. Football has become so quick and so spectacular, again, as a direct result of the backpossilor. It is, to me, an underrated moment in football history.
“现在他们都像奥林匹克十项全能运动员。他们都长得像中量级拳击手。我认为我们现在拥有的是一项完全不同的运动。它更快，更有活力。球员必须更健康。足球变得如此迅速和壮观，这直接归功于回传球规则。对我来说，这是足球史上被低估的时刻。”
Everyone that I talk to for this story brought up the same player. an underrated moment in football history. Everyone that I talked to for this story brought up the same player. A goalkeeper who really represents just how far the game has come since this rule changed back in 1992. His name is Ederson and he's this incredibly athletic Brazilian, he's got a neck tattoo the size of his neck. And Ederson is a very good goalkeeper in the traditional sense. He's a big guy with really strong hands,
我为这个故事采访的每个人都提到了同一个球员。足球史上被低估的时刻。我为这个故事采访的每个人都提到了同一个球员。一位真正代表了自1992年规则改变以来比赛进步了多少的守门员。他的名字叫埃德森，他是一位令人难以置信的运动型巴西人，他的脖子上有一个和他脖子一样大的纹身。埃德森在传统意义上是一位非常优秀的守门员。他是一个身材高大、双手非常强壮的家伙，
he's very agile, good at blocking shots. But Ederson has spellbinding foot skills. He's incredible with a bullet his feet. Ederson plays for the English club Manchester City, who have one of the best coaches in the world, a man named Pep Guardiola. And Guardiola started using Ederson in a way that basically no goalkeeper had been used before.
他非常敏捷，擅长封堵射门。但埃德森拥有令人着迷的脚下技术。他脚下的球感令人难以置信。埃德森效力于英超俱乐部曼城，他们拥有世界上最好的教练之一，一个名叫佩普·瓜迪奥拉的人。瓜迪奥拉开始以一种基本上以前没有守门员被使用过的方式使用埃德森。
Ederson is a playmaker. He starts attacks from Manchester City. He'll hit the bull 50 yards. He can hit the bull 5 yards. But some everything he does with the bull is with the purpose. He's treated as part of the team because of that. In many ways, Ederson feels like a unique talent, but at every level of soccer coaches are treating goalkeepers more like full members of the team.
埃德森是一位组织核心。他从曼城发起进攻。他可以长传50码。他可以短传5码。但他所做的一切都是有目的的。正因为如此，他被视为球队的一部分。在许多方面，埃德森感觉像是一个独特的天才，但在足球的各个层面，教练们都把守门员视为球队的正式成员。
Today, Justin Bryant is the goalkeeping coach for the North Carolina State Women's team, and he says that when they're recruiting, they like to look for goalkeepers who can play the ball with their feet and possess the ball out of the back. Last year, NC State had a star goalkeeper named Sydney Wooten. She took us to two sweet 16s. She had shutouts against schools like North Carolina Chapel Hill, University of Virginia, and Wooten was very short for goalie. But she was an incredible athlete with great leaping ability and very fast feet, but mainly she was such a good striker of the ball, such a good passer. And so the team developed a good striker of the ball, such a good passer.
今天，贾斯汀·布莱恩特是北卡罗来纳州立大学女子队的守门员教练，他说他们在招募时，喜欢寻找能够用脚处理球并能从后场控球的守门员。去年，北卡罗来纳州立大学有一位明星守门员名叫悉尼·伍顿。她带我们进入了甜蜜16强。她对阵北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校、弗吉尼亚大学等学校时保持零封。伍顿作为守门员来说非常矮。但她是一位令人难以置信的运动员，拥有出色的跳跃能力和非常快的脚步，但主要是她是一位非常出色的射手，非常出色的传球手。所以球队发展出了
And so the team developed a whole tactic of playing the ball out from the back, based around Wooten's foot skills. Wooten wasn't just known for preventing the other team from scoring, although she did that too. She was a valuable part of the team's offensive strategy. And so in a way, this rule that initially seemed so unfair to goalkeepers has ultimately made them a bit more like everyone else. Yeah, absolutely. I think the grand narrative of the Backpast law is that it had disastrous early effects.
一套基于伍顿脚下技术的从后场传球的完整战术。伍顿不仅以阻止对方球队得分而闻名，尽管她也做到了这一点。她是球队进攻策略中宝贵的一部分。所以从某种意义上说，这条最初对守门员看起来如此不公平的规则，最终让他们变得更像其他人了。“是的，绝对是。我认为回传球规则的宏大叙事是它产生了灾难性的早期影响。”
It caused goalkeepers to question their very existence, and then over the course of the next 10 or 20 years, it brought them back into the family. You still have individualistic, high-classic, loner personalities, but you know, we are in a very real sense more a part of the team now. This year, the International Football Association Board made a few more tweaks to the rules. There's one change in particular that's causing a few little problems. From now on, goal kicks don't have to leave the penalty box. And teams are struggling to figure it out. Players are making mistakes, just like they did back in 1992.
“它导致守门员质疑他们存在的意义，然后在接下来的10到20年里，它把他们带回了大家庭。你仍然有个人主义、反传统、孤独的个性，但你知道，我们在非常真实的意义上现在更多地成为了球队的一部分。”今年，国际足球协会理事会又对规则做了一些调整。有一个变化特别引起了一些小问题。从现在开始，球门球不必离开禁区。球队正在努力弄清楚这一点。球员们正在犯错，就像他们在1992年所做的那样。
It's hard to say right now if this will be an important rule change. We probably won't know for a couple of decades. But if we've learned anything from the back pass law, it's that anytime you tinker with the rules of the sport, you never know what might happen. The back best rule didn't just spring forth fully formed from the forehead of FIFA. One man claims that he was the one who invented it, and he has the facts to back him up after this. So I'm back in the studio with Emmett and he's got one more little detail
现在很难说这是否会成为一个重要的规则改变。我们可能要过几十年才知道。但如果我们从回传球规则中学到了什么，那就是每当你修补一项运动的规则时，你永远不知道会发生什么。回传球规则并非完全从国际足联的脑海中凭空产生。一个人声称是他发明了它，并且他在那之后有事实支持他的说法。所以我回到了演播室，和埃米特在一起，他还有最后一个小细节
to add to the story of the back pass law. Yes, so one thing that we didn't get into and the story proper was like, who specifically came up with this idea for the back pass law? That's right. I guess I kind of assumed it was like this, the collective wisdom of specifically came up with this idea? For the back best of all. Right. I guess I kind of assumed it was like this, the collective wisdom of FIFA came up with a lot.
要添加到回传球规则的故事中。“是的，所以我们没有在故事正文中深入探讨的一件事是，谁具体想出了回传球规则这个主意？”“没错。我猜我以为这是某种集体智慧……”具体想出了这个主意？为了回传球规则。没错。我猜我以为这是某种集体智慧，国际足联想出了这个规则。
Right, right. There's sort of, you know, that just sort of the wisdom of a bunch of guys in some boardroom somewhere, collectively came up with this idea. But, exactly. But that is also what I assumed. But as I was talking to Adam Hurrey, who was the football, the soccer journalist,
“对，对。某种程度上，你知道，就是一群人在某个董事会会议室里，集体想出了这个主意。”“但，完全正确。这也是我所假设的。但当我与足球记者亚当·赫里交谈时，”
he told me that he recently got a message from a journalist in Georgia who had some slightly more specific info. And you mean Georgia, the country? Yeah, Georgia, the country. That's the one. There was a game in Georgia this week and a journalist out there sent me a DM on Twitter saying, you're going to enjoy this. There's a guy here in the press room who claims to have invented the backpast law.
他告诉我，他最近收到了一位格鲁吉亚记者的消息，对方有一些稍微具体一点的信息。“你是说格鲁吉亚，那个国家？”“是的，格鲁吉亚，那个国家。就是那个。”本周在格鲁吉亚有一场比赛，那里的一位记者在推特上给我发了私信说：“你会喜欢这个的。这里新闻室里有个家伙声称他发明了回传球规则。”
So yeah, so this man's name was and I'm probably going to butcher this but so can Yashvili. Okay. Yashvili. Mm-hmm. Sounds good. Sounds good to me. And apparently he's walking around the press room of this stadium telling, you know, anyone who would listen all the foreign journalists who are there covering the game, but he invented the back pass long. And he is holding this fax as proof. And what did the fax say? Well, it was from FIFA, it was written in 1994, you know, a couple of years after the law went into effect. And it was essentially a thank you fax. We're most grateful to Mr. Yashelief contributing directly to the realization of this new rule, which is greatly contributed to the development of football worldwide. We appreciate the work
“所以，这个人的名字是——我可能会读错——索坎·亚什维利。”“好的。亚什维利。”“嗯。”“听起来不错。听起来不错。”“显然，他正在体育场的新闻室里走来走去，告诉任何愿意听的人，所有在那里报道比赛的外国记者，他发明了回传球规则。而且他拿着这份传真作为证据。”“那传真上写了什么？”“嗯，那是来自国际足联的，写于1994年，你知道，在规则生效几年后。这本质上是一份感谢传真。‘我们非常感谢亚什维利先生直接为实现这一新规则做出的贡献，这极大地促进了足球在全球的发展。我们感谢所有想法有助于改进我们所热爱的运动的先驱们的工作。’”
of all pioneers whose ideas help to improve our beloved sport. And you know, this was this was the first that I or I think basically anyone who's written about this has ever really heard of this guy. His name is very rarely been mentioned or if ever in the history of this backpast law. Despite it being one of the most seismic events in football history, especially in modern football. He's a real unsung hero. Yeah definitely. I've sent him an email at this Georgian guy. I carefully translated it into Georgian and everything, which is a beautiful language by the way. And he didn't get back to me, so I'm really sad about it because I've been good to
“你知道，这是我，或者我想基本上任何写过这个的人，第一次真正听说这个人。他的名字很少被提及，如果曾经被提及的话，在回传球规则的历史中。尽管它是足球史上最震撼的事件之一，特别是在现代足球中。他是一个真正的无名英雄。”“是的，绝对。我给他发了一封电子邮件，这个格鲁吉亚人。我仔细地把它翻译成了格鲁吉亚语等等，顺便说一句，那是一种美丽的语言。但他没有回复我，所以我真的很伤心，因为我本来可以
get his input in here. Yeah, and sadly we still still have not heard back from Mr. Yosh-Feli. And yeah, there's really nothing that's really been written about this guy. And I don't, I'm hoping that we're not spreading misinformation here, but Adam sent me a copy of the facts and it looks fairly legit to both of us. I mean, as far as I'm concerned, that his story is watertight.
得到他的意见。”“是的，遗憾的是我们仍然没有收到亚什维利先生的回复。而且，真的没有什么关于这个人的文章。我希望我们没有在这里传播错误信息，但亚当发给了我一份传真副本，在我们看来它看起来相当合法。我的意思是，就我而言，他的故事是无懈可击的。”
I've got no reason to doubt him. The facts looks legit to me. And, you know, this idea has to come from somewhere and no one else has ever been credited with it, so why not? So, yeah, Roman, do you want to see the facts I can show it to you? Totally. I can show it to you here. So, this is, yeah, take a look at my laptop screen. Oh, well, it's a scan of a wrinkle facts.
“我没有理由怀疑他。传真看起来很合法。而且，你知道，这个想法必须来自某个地方，而且没有其他人被归功于它，所以为什么不呢？所以，是的，罗曼，你想看那份传真吗？我可以给你看。”“当然。我可以在这里给你看。”“所以，这是，是的，看看我的笔记本电脑屏幕。”“哦，好吧，这是一份皱巴巴的传真扫描件。”
Yeah, and I guess what I like about this is like when you think about the evolution of sports, or if you tell the long story of the evolution of a game, the heroes are, you know, players and maybe coaches to coaches who come up with cool ideas about different ways to play and adapt their tactics or their style of play. But rules are important too. The game is contained by a set of rules and those rules need to change at times to adapt
“是的，我想我喜欢这一点的是，当你思考体育的演变，或者如果你讲述一场比赛演变的漫长故事时，英雄是球员，也许是教练，那些想出关于不同比赛方式、调整战术或比赛风格的酷点子的教练。但规则也很重要。比赛被一套规则所包含，这些规则有时需要改变以适应
to the way that the game is being played. Maybe there's a heroic Georgian man who deserves more credit than he's gotten so far. So here's to you, Mr. Josh Philly. Yeah. And your important contribution to the evolution of soccer. Change soccer forever. That's awesome. Cool.
比赛进行的方式。也许有一位英雄般的格鲁吉亚人值得比他目前得到的更多的赞誉。所以，敬你，亚什维利先生。”“是的。以及你对足球演变的重要贡献。永远改变了足球。太棒了。酷。”
What a great detail. Thanks, Emma. Yeah. Thank you. 99% invisible was produced this Week By Emmett Fitzgerald Mix and Tech Production By Sherev Yusuf, Music By Sean Rial Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Chris Barupet, Avery Truffan, Vivian
“多好的细节。谢谢，埃米特。”“是的。谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，谢列夫·优素福混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、克里斯·巴鲁佩特、艾弗里·特鲁凡、薇薇安·
Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Michael Cox, who we also spoke with for this story. His new book, The Mixer, is a great look at the evolution of soccer tactics since the Backpass Rule. Adam Hurrey also is a book called Football Cleshays, all about the language we use to describe the beautiful game. And if you want to read more about Justin Bryan's professional career in England, he's got a memoir called Small Time.
李、索菲亚·克拉茨克、乔·罗森伯格，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。本周特别感谢迈克尔·考克斯，我们也为这个故事采访了他。他的新书《混音器》很好地回顾了回传球规则以来足球战术的演变。亚当·赫里也有一本名为《足球陈词滥调》的书，全是关于我们用来描述这项美丽运动的语言。如果你想阅读更多关于贾斯汀·布莱恩特在英国的职业生涯，他有一本名为《小人物》的回忆录。”
You can find links to all of them on our website. We are a project of 91.7KALW in St. Francisco, we have produced, on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRXF fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But you can get them all to us.
“你可以在我们的网站上找到所有这些链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，我们在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心广播街制作。99%隐形是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm找到他们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@节目，99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。但你可以通过以下方式联系我们。”
We're open at 99PI.org. Radio tilp you. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我们在99PI.org。Radiotopia。来自PRX。你。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。”